-Before we move on, we would
like to take a moment.
This weekend,
five people were killed
and many more were injured
when a gunman opened fire
at an LGBTQ nightclub
in Colorado.
Our hearts go out to the victims
and their families,
and to the entire
LGBTQ community.
One of our writers, Jenny Hagel,
is gay,
and she's here to comment.
-Thanks, Seth.
When I read the news about
Colorado on Sunday morning,
I was shocked.
But also, I wasn't shocked.
Because sadly, our culture
is filled with messages
that there is something wrong
with queer people.
That we are, at best, weird
and, at worst, sick.
And those messages,
whether it's something small,
like telling a little boy
he can't wear nail polish,
or something big,
like passing a law
that says queer people
can't adopt children,
they all contribute to the
dehumanization of queer people.
And once a group of people
is seen as less than human,
it's easy to hurt them.
I'm sure that for many,
what happened in Colorado
will be seen as the result
of our nation's obsession
with guns,
and that's part of it, for sure.
But it's also
the result of our culture's
deep-seated
homophobia and transphobia,
our unhealthy relationship
with masculinity,
and our nation's tendency
to allow religion
to be used
as a cover for prejudice.
And the way our nation's history
of racism intersects with
and compounds all those things.
Now, that's a lot to untangle,
and I don't know how to do it.
So, instead,
I just wanted to say
that despite the millions
of voices in our culture
saying that there is something
wrong with queer people,
that we're sick or deviant
or predatory
or just a little off,
we are totally, 100% normal.
We live the same way
that everyone else does.
We want the same things.
We are great in the same ways
and boring in the same ways.
We're just regular people.
If you're queer, I wanted to say
that I see you
and I'm grieving with you.
And in this week
of giving thanks,
one thing I'm deeply,
deeply thankful for
is the LGBTQ community.
And if you're queer
but you're not out,
because you don't feel
ready to be
or because it's not safe
for you to be,
I see you, too,
and I think you are great
and perfect
just the way you are.
Nothing about us
needs to be fixed,
but there is
something in America
that desperately needs fixing,
and I hope we figure out soon
how to do it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
-Jenny Hagel, everyone.
Thank you, Jenny.